ahora mismo es prioritario encontrar
cuanto antes a estos cinco tripulantes
Porque según ha explicado el
contralmirante estadounidense que ha
ofrecido la rueda de prensa les quedan
entre 70 y 90 horas de oxígeno y ese
plazo se cumpliría el próximo miércoles
por la mañana así que se Está realizando
una búsqueda a contrarreloj en la que
participan varias agencias
estadounidenses y también canadienses
además se les Busca en el fondo del
Océano Atlántico con submarinos y barcos
comerciales también y con boyas de
sonido pero también se les Busca en la
superficie del Océano Atlántico porque
no se descarta que el submarino haya
salido a flote y es importante contactar
con ellos antes de que se pierda la
comunicación en esa rueda de prensa El
contraalmirante estadounidense ha
explicado que el proceso de búsqueda se
está llevando a cabo en una zona Pues
que presenta una serie de riesgos y de
desafíos porque es muy remota por eso se
está contando con el apoyo como decía de
numerosas agencias de hecho desde aquí
desde Nueva York ha partido hace muy
poquito un avión c-130 para ayudar en
esas labores de búsqueda de como digo
cinco pasajeros el contra almirante
estadounidense no ha querido hacer
ningún comentario sobre quiénes son esas
cinco personas por respeto a ellos y a
sus familiares lo que sí sabemos o por
lo menos eso es a lo que apuntan la
mayoría de los medios de comunicación
aquí es que entre los tripulantes habría
un británico Millonario de 59 años que
al parecer habría compartido en sus
redes sociales que iba a realizar este
viaje único un viaje que cuesta cerca de
250.000 dólares con otros dos
exploradores con otros dos expertos
legendarios y que este iba a ser uno de
los pocos viajes que se realizarán en el
2023 porque este invierno en esa zona
frente a las costas de Terranova en
Canadá el tiempo iba a ser el peor que
se veía en los últimos 40 años se trata
de un viaje que dura aproximadamente
ocho días aunque la inversión es
solamente de 8 horas y que permite a sus
pasajeros ver muy de cerca como nunca
antes habrán visto los restos del
Titanic en el fondo del Océano Atlántico